I'm such a Grinch the Grinch or dr.
Seuss is the Grinch or How the Grinch
Stole Christmas whatever
so the Grinch is the retelling of dr.
Seuss's How the Grinch Stole Christmas
or it's a retelling of the Ron Howard
movie starring Jim Carrey is a grand
join is they have once again taken a
story that's perfect as a half an hour
tale and patted it to make it longer
than it should be The Grinch hates
Christmas as always he hangs out in his
mancave up on a mountain overlooking
Whoville he does not like the who's in
Whoville whose love Christmas so one day
he's like you know what I'm gonna take
all their gifts I don't know why I'm
even explaining the plot you know that's
the plot this time around we have
Benedict Cumberbatch voicing the Grinch
big Cumberbatch fan wasn't really a fan
of his Grinch I kind of felt like they
got the 99-cent dr. house like the
99-cent Hugh Laurie but honestly I felt
like his Grinch felt flat for me the
best scene with him is also when the
trailer he's in the store he's eating
the pickle he spits it back in the jar
puts it back in the lady's basket it's
basically in this whole scenario he's
being a bit of a prick and I liked it he
cracked me up but it was more due to the
animation rather than Benedict
Cumberbatch's voice acting and like I
said this movie like the Jim Carrey
Grinch movie I feel like they just have
a lot of padding like they're just
making things up to happen in this movie
so they can just get to the point which
is when he steals Christmas bafflingly
enough because I'm not a huge fan of the
Jim Carrey Grinch I prefer the Jim
Carrey Grinch is plot to this movie's
plot I like the fact that he felt like
he was being accepted and then it just
totally crash and that's when he lost
his mind moment like that doesn't happen
in here this movie's actually filled
with moments and scenarios that make the
Grinch likable it addresses his hearts
two sizes too small but it's not the
Grinch comes across as a curmudgeon
standoffish like a grump but then he'll
do things like pet his dogs heads smile
at his dog the Grinch puffs up his hair
and looks at Max's dog Andy twiddles
with his hair and it kind of smiles
about it he's like oh I can't wait for
breakfast and he's like says that with a
grin there's even a scene where I don't
want to spoil it for you in case you
want to watch the movie but there's a
scene where a character wants to go off
with their family and the Grinch is like
all right I understand you should go
with your family I'm like said the
Grinch never how is this person a Grinch
he's just kind of a grumpy dude he's
kind of had a low in his life he's gonna
hit that face that everybody in their
life hits at least once but he's not bad
he's a bachelor essentially it's all is
he just a dude who lives on
with his dog yes really loud neighbors
who play really loud music have really
bright lights shining in his window in
his HOA won't do anything about it so he
just takes matters into his own hands I
feel for the guy I really do I feel like
in this movie they made the Grinch Carl
Fredricksen he's a grumpy old dude who
lives alone who standoffish she puts up
his walls he's like I don't like people
but you know deep down he has a heart of
gold and by the end of the movie it's
gonna show that with that's the Grinch
he's already done nice things before his
heart grew three sizes I understand why
they're trying to make the Grinch
likable he's a dog person after all so I
get it and I see that they were trying
to do that they're trying to make the
Grinch more relatable like he's grumpy
but how a human being would be grumpy
some people would be like oh I
understand this a more applicable
message to me but I feel like no one
ever really needed that because we all
kind of got the message of the original
Grinch movie right not like they made
him particularly relatable in their
movies like this always give me that
feeling of the movie Pearl Harbor where
people come to see a specific thing like
we watch a Grinch movie to watch The
Grinch steal Christmas we watched Pearl
Harbor to see the Pearl Harbor same but
those scenes are so small in the scope
of a cinematic runtime what to do we've
got to make stuff up and that's fine but
the stuff you make up to put in there to
make the movie long enough to get a
theatrical release it should be
interesting really me griping about the
Grinch and how he doesn't act like a
Grinch it's just secondary it's all
secondary to the fact that the plot is
just boring guys in the end some of the
animation looked really good in this
movie but this movie was literally I was
shutting down I was going to sleep while
I was watching it I felt myself turning
green I felt my heart shrinking to sizes
that day humbug I've bitched about this
movie enough I'm just gonna say I'm not
gonna remember this Grinch movie in
t-minus one day yeah I already forgot
right so the Grinch again have you seen
it what did you think about it or what's
your favorite Christmas or holiday
animated movie that you loved whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]